Venezuela está viviendo sus peores momentos.
El desastre es tan grande, que la que antaño
era una de las compañías de petróleo más
grandes y poderosas del mundo, PDVSA, hoy
está prácticamente en quiebra y cada vez
tiene más problemas, incluso, para extraer
petróleo.
Un momento, ¿que la empresa de petróleo
del país con las mayores reservas de todo
el mundo tiene problemas para extraerlo?
Pues sí, tal como lo escucháis, en este
vídeo os lo contamos…
Amigos, creo que todos lo conocemos: Venezuela
está viviendo una auténtica catástrofe,
un desastre no solo económico sino, sobre
todo, humanitario.
Un desastre tan enorme que ha provocado que
en los últimos años, atentos, entre 3 y
4 millones de venezolanos hayan abandonado
el país.
Es decir, más 1 de cada 10 habitantes.
Y la verdad… no puede sorprendernos.
Fijaos, según las últimas estadísticas,
el 87% de la población, el 87%, casi 9 de
cada 10 venezolanos son pobres… Y, ojo,
porque la mayoría de la población de Venezuela,
el 60% no solo es pobre sino que vive en condiciones
de extrema pobreza.
Pero...no solo eso… Venezuela está en llamas…
Según los datos del Observatorio Venezolano
de Conflictividad Social, en 2017 se registraron
casi 10.000 protestas por todo el país, más
de 27 al día.
Y lo que es aún peor:
(Según datos de Luisa Ortega, ex Fiscal General,
desde 2015 la policía, la Guardia Nacional,
el Ejército y los diferentes servicios de
inteligencia han asesinado a más de 8.000
personas.
Por supuesto, la mayoría de ellos, opositores
al régimen.)
Crisis, hambre, violencia, represión… todo
apunta a que Venezuela va a vivir próximamente
una crisis de refugiados de dimensiones colosales.
Porque amigos, seamos sinceros, la cosa no
pinta nada pero que nada bien.
(Veréis, durante años, la “revolución
bolivariana” de Chávez, Maduro y compañía
tuvo un gran aliado, y no hablamos de Cuba,
ni de Rusia ni de cualquier otro país, sino
del petróleo… el oro negro que financió
la “revolución”.
Durante mucho tiempo, los ingentes ingresos
de esta materia prima financiaron todas las
políticas del régimen sin que las consecuencias
importaran absolutamente nada.)
Es decir, ¿Que las fábricas cerraban?
¿Que la inversión extranjera salía huyendo
del país?
No importaba nada porque, amigos, ahí estaban
los dólares del petróleo.
Sin embargo… ahora todo eso está a punto
de terminarse.
Sí, en Venezuela hay mucho, muchísimo petróleo.
Pero… una cosas es tener petróleo y otra
muy distinta ser capaz de explotarlo.
¿Sabíais que PDVSA está a punto de colapsar
prácticamente del todo?
Atentos.
LA CAÍDA DE PDVSA
Petróleos de Venezuela, PDVSA, fue creada
por decreto gubernamental en 1976 para integrar
todos los activos petrolíferos nacionalizados
por el Estado…
Esta empresa pronto se convirtió en un coloso
de talla mundial.
¿Sabéis por qué?
Pues entre otras cosas porque esta compañía
posee las mayores reservas del planeta…
y, ojo, que no hablamos de poca cosa:
son más de 300.000 millones de barriles de
crudo certificados, más que las de Arabia
Saudita, Emiratos, Rusia o cualquier otra
potencia petrolera.
[Sí, es verdad, lo hemos contado aquí, el
petróleo venezolano no es de la mayor calidad,
pero… no importa.
Estamos hablando de una cantidad impresionante
de recursos, casi el 20% de todas las reservas
mundiales conocidas.]
(Pues bien, el caso es que esta compañía,
PDVSA, alcanzó su pico de producción en
1998, un año antes de la llegada al poder de Hugo
Chávez.
En aquel momento PDVSA estaba extrayendo 3
millones y medio de barriles al día.
Desde entonces, las cosas han cambiado bastante.
En 2013 cuando falleció Hugo Chávez la producción
se había reducido en 1 millón de barriles
diarios…)
Un momento, ¿Un millón menos?
¿Será acaso que al gobierno bolivariano
de Hugo Chávez no le gustaba el petróleo?
¿Sería cosa de algún retorcido plan para
diversificar la economía venezolana?
Pues… lo cierto es que no.
Todo lo contrario.
Hugo Chávez quería elevar la producción
hasta los 5 millones de barriles.
El problema es que, simplemente, no fueron
capaces de hacerlo.
Pero si pensáis que los resultados del comandante
fueron malos, es que no habéis visto nada…
Porque desde que Nicolás Maduro llegó al
poder la producción se ha hundido hasta los
1,8 millones de barriles.
[Es decir, mientras países como Estados Unidos
han doblado su producción, Venezuela produce
la mitad de petroleo que cuando comenzó la
revolución.
Menudo éxito]
¿Y pensáis que esto es lo peor?
Pues no, lo peor es que las previsiones son
aún mucho, pero que muchos peores para los
próximos años.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto puede que
te estés haciendo una pregunta, ¿Qué diantres
está pasando con PDVSA?
LAS CLAVES DE UN DESASTRE ANUNCIADO
La historia de PDVSA, amigos, ha sido la historia
de un desastre anunciado.
El mejor ejemplo lo encontramos en el complejo
de refinamiento de Paraguaná, compuesto
uno de los mayores
complejos de refinamiento
el planeta.
Durante años fue el orgullo industrial de
Venezuela, la joya de La Corona.
Sin embargo, hoy…. apenas opera al 15% de
su capacidad… y todo tipo de accidentes
son habituales, ¿Por qué?
(“No hay mantenimiento como tal.
Chuparon todo lo que pudieron de PDVSA sin
invertir.
Ya no queda nada que exprimir” Pablo Céspedes,
operador de planta.
Y este no es un caso extraordinario.
Lo cierto es que la mayoría de las instalaciones
de la petrolera se encuentran en pésimo estado.
(A finales de Octubre, en el mismo complejo
de refinamiento de Paraguaná, la refinería
de Amuay, vertió a la bahía más 200.000
galones de gasolina;
apenas unos días después , otra refinería
del complejo, la refinería Cardón sufrió
un incendió que los bomberos apenas pudieron
contener por no tener ni siquiera espuma con
la que enfrentarse a las llamas.)
Y así suma y sigue.
Pero… ¿Cómo creéis que se ha llegado
a este punto?
(Pues, vereis, el gobierno chavista siempre
vió a PDVSA como una especie de vaca lechera
donde podría obtener todos los recursos que
necesitaba para su “revolución bolivariana”…
el problema es que la industria del petróleo
requiere muchas inversiones, inversiones que
el gobierno venezolano simplemente no quiso
realizar.)
Y eso a pesar de que endeudó a PDVSA hasta
las cejas.
Por cierto, ¿Sabéis qué deuda tiene hoy
esta compañía?
Pues atentos al dato… no hablamos de 1000
ni de 5000, sino de 90.000 millones de dólares.
Una fortuna con la que Venezuela podría haber
comprado, incluso, multinacionales del calibre
de Goldman Sachs, Nike o Siemens.
¡Qué se dice pronto!
No me digáis que Venezuela no hubiera salido ganando.
Pero.... ¿pensáis que esto es todo?
Qué va.
Además utilizaron a la empresa para enchufar,
colocar, contratar a miles y miles de partidarios,
amigos, familiares… con lo que PDVSA cada
vez tuvo menos y menos recursos.
Y aún más, por si no fuera suficiente el
régimen chavista colocó en los puestos de
dirección a personal no cualificado y sin
experiencia, al tiempo que despidió y ahuyentó
por sus ideas políticas a miles y miles de
empleados que sí tenían muchísima experiencia.
[Sí, así es como PDVSA se ha quedado sin
dinero y sin recursos humanos.]
Ahora ya podemos entender por qué la producción
de petróleo no hace más que caer.
Por supuesto, las consecuencias de todo esto
para el país son… terribles.
LAS CONSECUENCIAS
El petróleo es fundamental para la economía
venezolana…
[sobre todo desde que no queda ninguna otra
industria en pie.]
La dependencia es tan grande que el petróleo
genera el 95% de todas las ganancias en divisas
extranjeras, en dólares por ejemplo.
Y estas divisas, amigos, son las que Venezuela
necesita para poder importar alimentos, fármacos,
gasolina - sí, Venezuela hoy tiene que importar
gasolina - o cualquier otra cosa.
Pero claro… como la producción de petróleo
no hace más que caer… pues el país cada
vez puede importar menos cosas.
Y ¿sabéis que?
Como en Venezuela ya no se produce literalmente
nada y hay que importarlo todo, el menguante
dinero del petróleo ya no da para pagar todas
las facturas.
Pero… claro, si se gasta más dinero del
que se ingresa… el dinero se termina…
y eso es, precisamente, lo que le está pasando
a Venezuela, que según algunos cálculos
apenas cuenta ya con 10.000 millones de dólares
en reservas extranjeras, la cifra, ojo, más
baja en 40 años..
Es decir… Cuando se termine ese dinero ya
no se podrá importar absolutamente nada más
que lo que pueda comprar con lo ingrese por
petróleo… que es cada vez menos.
¿Veis donde está el problema?
(Hasta ahora el gobierno de Nicolás Maduro
ha tratado de ganar tiempo recurriendo a los
mercados internacionales para emitir deuda…
con tipos escandalosos, en algunos de hasta
el 40%, como ya vimos aquí en un pasado vídeo.)
Evidentemente, amigos, emitir deuda con tipos
implícitos del 40% supone ir de cabeza a
la ruina.
Y en cualquier caso hoy ya no es ni siquiera
una posibilidad.
De hecho, tanto el gobierno de Venezuela como
PDVSA están incurriendo en default, es decir,
que no están pagando sus deudas.
(“S&P rebaja a nivel de default siete bonos
soberanos de Venezuela” Banca y Negocios)http://www.bancaynegocios.com/sp-rebaja-a-nivel-de-default-siete-bonos-soberanos-de-venezuela/
Otra vía que también han intentado ha sido
la del rescate chino… y los chinos, respondieron
y pusieron sobre la mesa préstamos por más
de 23.000 millones…
pero... todo tiene un límite y ya no están
dispuestos a seguir poniendo más dinero por nada.
Fijaos.
(“La petrolera china Sinopec demanda a PDVSA
por deudas no pagadas” OilPrice.)
La situación, amigos, es tan desesperada
que el gobierno de Cuba ha decidido embargar
el 49% que PDVSA tenía en una refinería
cubana como compensación por deudas impagadas.
Tal cual como lo escucháis,
¡Ni Cuba se fía ya del régimen de Maduro!
Y, así, ni más ni menos es cómo ha nacido
la última ocurrencia chavista: el Petro.
EL PETRO
Como hemos visto, cada día que pasa el gobierno
de Venezuela tiene menos acceso a las divisas
extranjeras… lo que evidentemente es un
problema enorme… porque sin divisas no hay
importaciones.
Pero en estas surgió una idea:
Las criptodivisas están de moda, así que,
¿por qué no lanzar
nuestra propia criptodivisa bolivariana? El Petro.
Claro que… el petro es una divisa muy particular...entre
otras cosas amigos porque está controlada
por el gobierno de Maduro.
En estas condiciones, os hago una pregunta,
¿Estaríais dispuestos a invertir un solo
euro, un solo dólar en esta nueva criptodivisa?
O dicho de otra forma ¿Pondríais vuestro
dinero en manos del gobierno venezolano?
[Yo lo tengo clarísimo… ni un centavo.]
(Y precisamente porque nadie en su sano juicio
haría tal cosa es por lo que el gobierno
de Venezuela ha tenido que respaldar esta
particular criptodivisa con petróleo.
Es decir, cada Petro estará garantizado por
un barril de petróleo de las reservas petroleras
de Venezuela, reservas que, por supuesto,
están en el subsuelo, claro.
De esta forma, el valor del petro queda, aparentemente,
vinculado al de esta materia prima).
¿Os parece que ahora suena mejor?
… pues… esperad un momento porque no podemos
olvidarnos de un detalle, un detalle muy pero
que muy importante:
las reservas de petróleo, amigos, se encuentran
también bajo el control del gobierno chavista.
Y yo me pregunto, ¿Realmente crees que este
gobierno va a conseguir explotar esas reservas?
Y aun en el caso de que lo lograra, ¿crees
que mantendría el respaldo del petro?
¿Y la tasa de conversión?
¿No se gastaría acaso los recursos generados?
¿No impondrá restricciones o regulaciones
que le beneficiaran?
Y sobre todo, ¿Para qué diantres arriesgarse
con los petros?
Por cierto, un apunte importante, el petro
no es convertible.
Es decir, aunque supuestamente está respaldado
por barriles de petróleo no lo podréis intercambiar
por ello, por ningún título que acredite
un derecho sobre esos barriles.
(“El petro es una criptomoneda que no es
cripto, respaldada por reservas que no lo
son.
Que sólo se puede monetizar con producción
que está colapsando y expedida por un Gobierno
en default y sin dólares”.
Francisco Monaldi, profesor del Instituto
Baker de la Universidad de Rice en Houston)
Amigos, el petro no parece más que una última
ocurrencia para ganar tiempo y tratar de obtener
el mayor número de dolares posibles aprovechando
el tirón de las criptomonedas y tal vez el
blanqueo de capitales… porque, ¿quién
pondrá los dólares sobre la mesa?
El caso, es que si esta criptodivisa no funciona…
y la verdad, eso parece algo bastante seguro…
al régimen chavista de Maduro parece quedarle
solo tres opciones:
primera, aceptar algún tipo de revuelta interna
y dejar de una u otra forma el poder, lo que
a día de hoy parece muy difícil;
segunda, emplear una mano aún más dura y
condenar a Venezuela a un desastre humanitario
incluso mayor;
o tercera, intentar por todos los medios que
chinos y rusos compran masivamente los recursos
nacionales del país, como las refinerías,
el petróleo y otras muchas materias primas.
Es decir, convertirse en una especie de colonia
malvendiendo todas y cada una de las joyas
de La Corona para que la élite chavista pueda
seguir disfrutando de su nivel de vida.
Amigos, si Nicolás Maduro y compañía continúan
en el poder, me parece que Venezuela difícilmente
tendrá un futuro mejor.
Pero ahora… turno para ti… ¿Estarías
dispuesto a cambiar tu dinero por petros?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like, compártelo y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si aun no las hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.